[music]
so i actually heard about this new indie
film alore from Evan rachel Wood the
star of the movie Instagram account
She's famous as delores from westworld
so you probably know who She is this
movie was the feature debut of the
Sanchez Brothers It is  a Canadian film
the main role that Evan rachel Wood
plays was originally written for a maale
She wants to do this role still and
really made it her own as a female here
and it definitely worked better being a
female so the of the movie I have a
bunch Evan rachel wood's performance
here as Laura is the biggest Bright spot
of this movie I'm going to say It's
already Oscar okay I'm not kidding This
is incredible I already knew She was
great in westworld this really shows her
acting chops and She doesn't  disappointed
If You're solely watching this movie for
the purpose of seeing her perform do it
She plays this mysterious character From
The gecko Very well keeps that Mystery
there So you don't know much about her
But open up She plays the crazy really
well  and Sometimes you still sympathize
with her and she just conveys so many
different feelings in a really really
Dark place The standout Scene for me
with her acting was actually The Scene
where we meet laura's brother and He's
in the wheelchair and He's bonding with
Eva and her  portrayal of just instant
jealousy being threatened that feeling
on her Face Where they zoomed in on her
and then She snapped was perfect perfect perfect
perfect playing someone Who's
obsessed with some bu especially a minor
Which is completely wrong can be very
daunting task and she kills it  here
another pro is obviously the girl plays
the miner Julie Sarah stone She has that
baby face So she's Perfect for this part
She plays innocent So well and she's the
complete opposite of laur but ends up
going through the same cycle Of An abuse
victim that Laura  had gone through learn
from her father and it is very hard to
watch ava go cuz you know how Young She
is and She does clearly have feelings of
warmth towards Laura but She's also
being kidnapped and she's scared and she
has a terrible Mother And now She's  with
a girl She trusted and liked but then
She took full advantage of her so it's a
lot of Complex thing going on here but
That's What made it so good to me and
the father played by Dennis o' is played
brilliantly he plays a guilty ritten  and
Dad someone you also sympathize with In
The Beginning a bit but then you start
learning more and more and like Why is
he so Nice to la Why is he giving her a
job Why is he paying for her rent We
find out It's for other reasons  of guilt
and he kind of keeps that Mystery well they
hinted it obviously when he gave
her a little bit of a Shoulder massage
in the office that role he plays There
is a very don't show your full cards
there just Show the guilt and He  does
that really well cuz you could always
tell There was something going on with
him that he wasn't saying But overall
you have three great performances here
and there's no overacting anywhere no
one ruined this movie It was a Joy to
watch this and story wise  I Loved it it
was really a 360 view on abuse here It's
that Hurt people Hurt people theme but
It doesn't in a really unique way you
can tell already laur is a character
Who's gone through some stuff She's
Broken person and then She acts out  on
it towards this innocent girl but then
you see this innocent girl Go through
what you assume Laura has been through
in some ways and then it turns out being
the father it really is rachel would
have said interviews Where she wanted to
betray the monster here and  that Monster
still was a kid at some Point so You're
learning How did they get to He What do
they think is Okay does her character
think that being with minor and
basically Holding hostage is ok it's
just a touchy subject It's daring for
the directors  go into I think it's more
of Just an observation there and It
shows you how this stuff happens And you
take from it what you think gets people
to that Point is anything justifiable is
Everything not justifiable That's for
you to decide while watching it I think
that betrayeds  that really well and I
think a really powerful scene here was
with Eva looking at the bus whether She
should leave or not now was her
opportunity to go but it really Again HD
that stockholm syndrome Why people stay
with abusers cuz Again did feel warm
for Laura  in a Sense and liked her
Company cuz She came from a Broken home
She Was just putting herself in even
more abuse and she finally Learns that
the end and breaks free which Coming
Around In The Script was done So well
and almost like laura's version of
Breaking  Free was not abusing someone
more relying on other people and doing Bad
things and hurting people like What was
done to her and making some sort of
peace with her Father And Ready To
actually face herself it seems like at
the end and I love How that beautifully
came  about where the two of them broke
free the same way One from her user and
An abuser from another abuser so it's
like a chain here and they learned a lot
about themselves so Again so many themes
going on here so much character study
very progressive and the  setting Here is
beautiful it looked great Perfect that
it was a dreary fall in Canada into a
very blizzard like Winter in Canada so
it fit the tone completely for this
character of Laura behind her It's a
very Dark movie It's heavy There's not a
Sign of humor  Here I like that it went
full in Although cuz lot of times they try
to throw in those campy scenes to
lighten it up and keep the audience
prepared But when I'm going to go Dark I
want to stay realistic and go Dark so i
was  Happy they did that approach I don't
think We see that enough anymore Again
this movie was fearless to me and props
of the directors and the actors for that
now like All My reviews I have pros and
cons very few cons here for me I
think  the Only Thing Missing to make
this an excellent movie was the score
was a little bland I felt like I wanted
more and I felt like There was some more
scenes I just needed some sort of music
Maybe that finch type Vibe in certain
scenes Where She's yelling  or Where It's
transitioning There's a lot of silence
which works a lot of points but I think
it just needs a little more music and a
little more uniqueness to it and I think
another thing that kind of angers me
was When laur starts Taking Eva out
Places  at points especially When they go
to a public swimming pool If you've
kidnapped somebody And you cherish
person you love him so much little odd
to risk that especially risking C by
police and Yes The Cop stop looking for
this girl but I'm sure  Someone would
recognize her Face from the town they're
in you suspend your disbelief there for
a little bit but overall I love this
movie I'm going to give it an 8.5 out of
10 I'm shocked I'm shocked in the Sense
Because I always peak sometimes reviews
Before I see a movie and this has been
getting a mixed reaction and I'm shocked
it was getting a mixed reaction it
should be getting more praised I think
the scripts Oscar okay and I think the
performances are especially Evan  rachel
would here I'm not kidding if you
read other reviews saying otherwise
they're wrong give this movie a shot
it's worth the rental It's only 6 bucks
against cheaper the movie ticket
powerful It's unique It's something you
haven't seen before and It's  great
acting All Around It's a great work of
art Please let me know what you think
of down below i' love to hear what you
think I respond to everyone let's get
the discussion going on this movie and
Please Subscribe I do a bunch more movie
reviews  TV reviews celebrity interviews
and much more so keep coming back
and I'll see you next time